hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today I'm going to be teaching
you about some of the major aspects of
Paramecium structure so a Paramecium is
a single-celled protozoan eukaryotic
cell comment in the environment and now
let's take a look at what it looks like
so it has kind of this oval shape it is
surrounded by what are known as cilia
the cilia are used for two main purposes
the first one is motility so locomotion
moving around and also for food capture
the way they function in food capture is
right here this cilia in this region
will actually beat in such a way that it
creates like a little whirlpool which is
really cool and it will help them direct
food into the sight o fair inks which is
also known as the oil group and then
down into the side of the stoma or this
felt mouth where it will collect into a
food vacuole then the food vacuole will
move through the cell digest the
contents and then eventually any waste
products that aren't needed by the cell
get expelled through the site appraoch
or anal core through a form of
exocytosis a few other things that keep
in mind Paramecium structure are the two
contractile vacuoles they're shown here
in blue so you have these two
contractile vacuoles they're surrounded
by this array of radiating ducts which
basically act to collect the water
remember that Paramecium is living
inside a hypotonic environment and what
this means is that there's a lot of
things dissolved in a Paramecium cell
and outside of it there's not much else
in the water there's a lot of water and
so water is constantly wanting to flow
down its concentration gradient from
outside the cell to inside the cell if
water was just allowed to constantly
flow in an end
the cell would swell and it would burst
these collecting channels around the
contractile vacuoles help to collect
water into the contractile vacuoles the
contractile vacuoles then contract and
expel water back outside the cell
helping it to Osmo regulate some other
things to keep in mind are in the cell
wall the cell wall also helps to protect
the cell from swelling from picking up
too much water and bursting the cell
wall is sometimes referred to as bee
pellicle and also there are two nuclei
in Paramecium there is the larger of the
two which is called the macro nucleus
the macro nucleus is responsible for
metabolic and other non reproductive
functions and the smaller micro nucleus
is responsible for the actual cell
division process when it's time for
Paramecium to reproduce to divide and so
those are the major components of
Paramecium structure check out my
playlist on other cell biology topics
including things like Osmo regulation
that the contractile vacuoles
participate in and then also things like
sexual and asexual reproduction and
endocytosis and other really cool topics
so check that out and thanks for
watching today I'll see you next time
bye